la situation et le débat discussion qui
sait si ce n'est qu'une discussion côté
de plus que ça d'ailleurs qui s'est
nouée ou qui se noue autour de l'article
24 de ce texte mérite que l'on fasse ce
point parce que le sénat
le sénat depuis la fin du mois de
novembre est précisément le 26 novembre
est désormais saisie de ce texte
lorsque je dis cela c'est pour rappeler
que nous sommes un système bicaméral que
nous avons deux chambres qui travaillent
et qui ont la charge de rédiger la loi
et personne d'autre ni commission
décider éventuellement par le premier
ministre ou tout autre type
d'institution la loi c'est l'assemblée
nationale et c'est le sénat qu'il la
rédige et le sénat depuis le 26 novembre
mettent au travail
sur l'ensemble de ce texte ce que je
souhaiterais vous dire c'est d'abord en
avant de laisser la parole très
rapidement rapportèrent ou plurielle
c'est que ce texte constitue
probablement l'une des plus importantes
réformes de sécurité de sécurité
intérieure pour la france depuis la
dernière loppsi 2011
en dehors des textes spécifiques
bien sûr de lutte contre le terrorisme
il est d'ailleurs assez malheureux il
faut le dire que en raison d'une
focalisation excessive sur l'article 24
l'opinion est très majoritairement perdu
de vue et finalement presque tout le
monde perdu vu son ambition initiale à
savoir de réorganiser de manière assez
profonde le cadre de la sécurité
intérieure en france on touche à des
domaines sensibles sur le plan juridique
et constitutionnel car là est l'enjeu
est tel que par exemple l'utilisation de
nouvelles technologies à des fins de
sécurité ou encore à la montée en
puissance des polices municipales et de
la sécurité privée
au vu de ces enjeux d'ailleurs nous
je regrette mais nous regrettons
collectivement que le législateur en
tant qu'illustrateur pardon que ce texte
n'est pas été éclairés ni par une étude
d'impact ni par un avis préalable du
conseil d'état
en réalité cela est de plus est d'autant
plus dommageable d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement lui même ne s'est pas caché
d'avoir tenu la plume des auteurs de la
proposition de loi ce qui est tout de
même singulier mais la réalité concrète
de cette ce process de cette manière de
faire fait que finalement il n'y a eu
aucun travail préparatoire qui viennent
éclairer comme c'est d'habitude le
parlement et donc il a fallu que nous
compensions par des consultations larges
que nous faisons habituellement a disons
les choses telles qu'elles sont mais
tout de même nous aurions eu d'un côté
l'avis du conseil d'état ou autre côté
l'étude d'impact cela aurait aidé sans
doute ou peut-être même éviter un
certain de crispation sur ce texte
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est on
est quand même dans une situation de
deux
d'impréparation disons très directement
générale de ce texte par l'exécutif et
que vraiment c'est tout à fait
regrettable alors ce que je souhaite
vous dire et j'en terminerai c'est que
cette affaire d'articles 24 et la
problématique que pose article 24 et
sans aucun doute l'exemple le plus
illustratif de cette non préparation et
il n'est pas banal d'ailleurs que le
parlement soit ainsi saisi
concomitamment de deux textes de textes
comportant des dispositions qui se
concurrencent sans parler de la
commission instituée
plus récemment seul évoqué tout à
l'heure sur cet article 24 alors que
nous sommes saisis au travail nous
sommes contents je voudrais dire quand
même un point positif
ce texte devait venir au sénat en séance
la semaine le 14 sept semaines le 14
décembre exactement et j'avais souhaité
compte tenu de la procédure d'urgence
qui avait été voulu que cela soit
reportée parce que les conditions de
travail ne paraissait pas sérieuses ont
fait les cas ne paraissait pas remplies
et d'ailleurs je dois dire que le
gouvernement l'avait acceptée alors il
l'a accepté et nous savons tous les cas
ce sera confirmé dans les heures qui
viennent que ce texte ne viendra pas en
séance publique avant le mois de mars
prochain les choses nous laisse un peu
de temps mais nous ne le savons que
depuis peu de temps
en réalité pour ne pas dire quelques
jours et non rapporteurs ont deux
rapporteurs de la commission des lois
ont donc travaillé
rapidement depuis n'ont pas terminé mais
à travailler rapidement depuis le 20
novembre
ayant entendu 56 personnes au total dans
le cadre de 18 auditions pour déjà un
nombre de 20h de d'heures d'audition et
de travail elles vont se continuer
naturellement au mois de janvier
et puis peut-être plus longtemps s'il le
faut pour arriver en séance 1 faire
arriver ce texte en séance au mois de
mars
voilà nous avons souhaité ce point
presse et je le redis pour vous dire
l'état des lieux l'état des constats et
ne pas vous donner ou de prêts solution
l'objectif n'est pas de vous donner une
pré solution d'ailleurs nous devrions et
nous devons le rapport définitif à la
commission des lois et à ses
commissaires en premier naturellement et
nous respecterons cet ordre des choses
mais compte tenu de l'actualité du
contexte nous a paru important de
pouvoir vous en parler aujourd'hui
[Musique]